cell phone video of a confrontation at a
Border Patrol checkpoint is stirring up
new controversy in the immigration
debate the California teacher posted
this video of Border Patrol agents
detaining her after she refused to say
if she was a US citizen
now the checkpoint was in New Mexico
about 35 miles from the border the video
has many wondering if she was within her
rights or had an obligation to comply
Matea via al is in Los Angeles Maday a
good morning good morning Shane Parmalee
was headed home from vacation with her
three children when she asked one of
them to start recording the videos have
generated thousands of views on Facebook
but it's also sparked a debate a heated
debate about immigration rights when
Shane Palmer Lee was stopped at this New
Mexico Border Patrol station she refused
to answer the agents questions the
middle-school teacher says she did it
after hearing her Latino friends talk
about their experiences at checkpoints
it made me feel sick want to get asked
knowing what my friends have been
through it just made me feel physically
ill they do more than ask that I'm a
citizen they will ask where my kids go
to school they'll ask what grade they're
in the last would type of job I have
Supreme Court the Supreme Court does
allow agents to set up checkpoints
within a hundred miles of the border and
ask questions about citizenship without
warrants what happens if I refuse to
answer your question here until your
answer I'm a teacher I'm on vacation I
got time she had the right to remain
silent she had the right to question why
was she's being detained
what other avenues can these Border
Patrol agents take to verify citizenship
well they need a reasonable suspicion
that the individual is either committing
a crime or is here on lawfully and
that's difficult to ascertain by someone
just saying I don't want to answer a
question
on Facebook some applauded parmalee's
activism others criticized her actions I
am sorry but you are disrespectful the
Border Patrol is doing a job that must
be done there are a lot of criticisms
that seem to basically be on this
logical fallacy that if you question
authority you're disrespectful and I
disagree are we free to go
power Li was released after about 90
minutes of being detained without
answering the question now Border Patrol
said in a statement that they want to
make sure that they understand what the
immigration status is they are allowed
to detain drivers for a reasonable
amount of time in order to verify
immigration status they also said that
they treat every individual that comes
through those checkpoints with respect
and dignity Gayle all right Thank You
Maria well he did say thank you at the
end you know when you look at the video
I know there's two sides but it seems
like he was just trying to do his job
well what I'm just trying to make a
point what I didn't hear from the
teacher was what she would suggest he do
otherwise I mean he said that a border
checkpoint he's got to find out if
you're supposed to be in there lawfully
or not how do you do that ask the
questions interesting conversation
mm-hmm Mariah thank you again